[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24
conmigo en el estudio más romeros a la
mar hoy vamos a hablar del alzhéimer una
enfermedad que todavía no tiene cura
pero que cada día sabemos más pues sí
recordemos es una enfermedad
neurodegenerativa y que todavía tiene
muchos misterios muchas preguntas por
responder algo que ha hecho
recientemente un estudio de la
universidad de cardiff que han
secuenciado centenares de miles de
genomas de personas distintas algunas
con alzheimer y otras sin y han
identificado 42 genes nuevos que podrían
estar relacionados con el riesgo de
sufrir alzhéimer entonces para hablar de
esto y de muchos otros factores
relacionados con esta enfermedad estamos
con el doctor oscar franco epidemiólogo
director de salud pública de la
universidad el profesor de salud pública
de la universidad de berna doctor
bienvenido al programa de salud de
directo américa o cuéntenos estos 42
genes se han visto que están
relacionados en parte con el sistema
inmune qué relación puede haber entre el
sistema inmune y el alzhéimer
en primer lugar mar esto es muy buena
noticia porque es un salto muy
importante en términos de los
conocimientos que tenemos sobre los
factores genéticos y el alzhéimer
sabíamos de 33 genes y ahora tenemos 42
nuevos o sea que más que duplica el
conocimiento que se tenía y lo que ayude
a entender también es que cuáles son los
mecanismos cuáles son las vías por las
cuales puede ocurrir la enfermedad y si
parece que las vías de inmunidad bien
inflamatorias están relacionados por
ejemplo en términos de la función inmune
la función inmune ayuda a limpiar por
así decirlo la basura que tenemos en
nuestro organismo a eliminar proteínas y
células muertas y es posible que ésta
está efecto de limpieza se disminuya o
que aumente en la forma en que nos
defendemos contra nosotros mismos
entonces esto lo que nos ayuda a
entender es que si está ocurriendo por
ese mecanismo quizás podamos desarrollar
estrategias tratamientos quizás
medicamentos que puedan ayudar a
prevenir el alzheimer ya mejorar la
calidad de vida en pacientes con
alzheimer hola doctor los saludo muy
buena tarde ya para usted le preguntó
entonces qué tan relacionado está el
alzhéimer con genética
y hasta ahora lo que se ha reportado es
que más o menos entre el 60 al 70 por
ciento relacionado con la genética sin
embargo en primer lugar la genética aún
está en desarrollo en grandes
poblaciones todavía estamos viendo los
resultados de estas grandes estudios
poblacionales y en segundo lugar que la
genética no actúa solo no importa los
genes que uno tenga porque tiene una
interacción muy compleja con muchos
otros factores como por ejemplo el
estilo de vida o los factores sociales
entonces así se tengan los genes si se
sigue un buen estilo de vida se puede
ayudar a prevenir y mejorar estaba
hablando de este estilo de vida no
hablamos de dieta sana de no fumar de
hacer ejercicio y también de ejercicios
cognitivos a lo largo de la vida todo
esto se asoció precisamente como decía -
alzheimer que puede explicar la relación
entre estos factores ambientales y el
desarrollo de la enfermedad
si hemos visto cómo hacer ejercicio por
ejemplo dormir bien y seguir una buena
dieta cuidarse en términos del estilo de
vida ayuda a prevenir oa mejorar un poco
lo que es el desarrollo cognitivo y el
deterioro que puede ocurrir ya con la
demencia y esto puede ser a través de
esos mecanismos que identifica vamos
ahora con estos factores genéticos a
través de mejorar la respuesta inmune
sabemos que el ejercicio ayuda a mejorar
la respuesta inmune pero también hacerlo
cardiometabólica hemos visto como
factores de riesgo cardiovasculares o
problemas cardiovasculares
también se relacionado con la demencia
entonces el estilo de vida juega un
papel muy importante y se debería
promover no solamente por la demencia
sino por muchos otros factores claro
pero el problema una de las cosas que se
me ocurren aquí es que al final llevar
un estilo de vida sano no está al
alcance de todo el mundo no también de
hecho se ha visto que los problemas
cardiovasculares están ampliamente
relacionados con a personas con menos
poder adquisitivo también fumar donde
puede ser que el alzhéimer termina
afectando de manera desproporcionada a
las clases sociales más bajas
así es y se ha visto que entre las
personas más pobres comparado con
aquellos que tienen mayor cantidad de
dinero que son más ricos más o menos
tienen un riesgo en un 50% más alto de
desarrollar demencia entonces sí es
importante reducir esas inequidades
sociales es importante
facilitar la educación y ayudar a que
las personas de diferentes estratos
puedan tener acceso a una dieta
saludable y a poder hacer ejercicio como
también lo hemos hablado aquí hay
muchísimas oportunidades de marc pues la
alimentación es muy importante en
nuestra salud nuestro cuerpo y cómo
funciona y cómo se pueden desarrollar
posibles enfermedades doctor le quiero
preguntar entonces si se prevé que la
cantidad de gente con demencia de
alzheimer crees que los próximos años
que podemos hacer al respecto
si se estima que tenemos entre unos 55 y
60 millones de personas en el mundo con
alzhéimer con demencia ahora mismo y se
espera que esa cantidad se duplique cada
20 años o sea que si miramos al 2050 se
tendría más o menos unos 140 millones de
personas con demencia lo que pasa es que
vivimos en una sociedad en una humanidad
que cada vez vivimos más tiempo y cada
vez estamos
sobreviviendo más y más años sin embargo
el sistema de salud del sistema de la
forma en que vivimos pues no se ha
adaptado y hemos oído por ejemplo como
las reformas pensionales que hacer con
las personas cuando se retiran y vemos
también cómo los factores sociales
juegan un papel primordial entonces
mantener la educación facilitar el
acceso a la educación de la población en
general reducir las inequidades y ayudar
a las personas cuando pasan las salidas
de pensionarse de retirarse a mantenerse
activas no solamente físicamente sino
también de manera intelectual
cognitivamente que puedan seguir
educándose que puedan estudiar que
puedan interactuar con otros
muy importante tener en cuenta eso
también pues para las políticas públicas
que se puedan desarrollar hacia el
futuro así es doctor muchísimas gracias
por estar con nosotros en salud como
siempre todos los miércoles aquí en
directo américa de france 24
gracias mar también por acompañarnos
como siempre todas las mañanas pasamos a
hablar con nuestro segundo invitado el
día